vou começar dizendo assim eu desconheço
um ser humano que vai passar por essa
existência sem ter contato com dois
substantivos extremamente importante pra
gente
felicidade e tristeza ok
desconheço e acho que vocês também o
problema de felicidade e tristeza para
quando virar epidemia existe epidemia de
felicidade isso é ruim porque a gente
perde noção da realidade existe epidemia
de tristeza nem explicar porque isso é
ruim também
essa região que a gente está vem
passando por uma epidemia de tristeza e
como que a gente lida com isso como que
a gente cura como que a gente trata
epidemia de tristeza no dia 5 de
novembro de 2015
todo mundo que morava que mora e que
pertence a essa região passou por um
crime ambiental e não saiu do outro lado
da mesma forma
todo mundo foi afetado no brasil inteiro
no mundo inteiro
eu fui afetado a trabalho e estava em
são paulo trabalhando às 16 horas no
telefone tocou e a minha companheira
falou logo se viu que estourou uma
barragem
não estou sabendo não entra no grupo da
escola porque nossos filhos estão lá
acampando itacolomi e provavelmente está
todo mundo apavorado
a partir disso eu pulei numa piscina que
eu não conseguia mais sair
nos três anos seguintes e até hoje eu
estou nadando e chego aqui pra falar com
vocês dessa experiência e como que a
gente lida com uma epidemia de tristeza
a gente veio para a região algumas vezes
ea gente fez um projeto chamado memórias
de mariana
esse projeto no início tinha o objetivo
de manter a vigilância no local
a gente fez oito episódios de um
documentário três ensaios fotográficos
ea gente conseguiu publicar mais de 30
artigos diversos veículos
o principal veículo que agregou tudo e
começou a distribuir para o mundo
inteiro
se eu perder jordani com essa
experiência eu tive acesso a algumas
pessoas desde o início a primeira vez
que eu consegui entrar no evento foi no
dia 10 de novembro de 2015
só cinco dias depois do crime ambiental
e eu consegui conhecer muitas pessoas
que trabalharam como curandeiros como
prevenção para essa epidemia não se
alastrar corpo de bombeiro polícia
militar
a brigada de defesa monte de gente
incrível
a partir disso e dessa experiência eu
comecei a catalogar ser humano
colecionar ser humano extraordinário
como que a gente faz para fazer com que
essas histórias se alastrem e que sirvam
também para controlar a epidemia que é
muito ruim para a região e para o nosso
país para tudo não tem jeito imagina
isso nossas fotos rodaram o mundo mas
mais do que isso nossas histórias
rodaram o mundo
eu quero dividir com vocês aqui
compartilhar com vocês quatro histórias
dessas quatro histórias
todo o aprendizado gerado por memórias
de mariana a gente pode sintetizar
nesses personagens
o primeiro deles é o fará para se tornou
um grande amigo a 5 e 30 da tarde do dia
5 de novembro a 5 e 30 na tarde do dia 5
de novembro toca o telefone do corpo de
bombeiro em belo horizonte do batalhão
de resgate especial bemat 15 30 uma hora
e meia depois fará pega um helicóptero
major da polícia militar pilotando
quatro pessoas de mahdi e o fará
sobrevoando vindo pra cá pra região
passaram por bento e viram que não
tinham o que fazer e que a brigada o
batalhão estava chegando para ajudar
bento e continuaram seguindo o fluxo da
lama foram chegando perto de paracatu
quando viram que para cá tu tava
tranquila todo mundo fazendo o que tinha
que fazer no dia a dia a gente no bar do
jairo tomando uma cervejinha os meninos
saindo da escola ou
indo jogar futebol eles apavoraram
porque do helicóptero
dava pra ver a lama se aproximando ea
população que ia ser simplesmente
dizimada
aí o diálogo que se seguiu foi o tenente
pará falando para o marajó que é
hierarquicamente superior a ele majó
pousou o helicóptero agora senão a gente
vai ver a morte de cerca de 200 pessoas
e uma já sabia que se ele pousasse o
helicóptero a chance de voar o
helicóptero de novo era mínima
então o salvamento e a ser de todo o
mundo da população e dos seis
tripulantes do helicóptero quando foi às
6 horas e 30 minutos duas horas e trinta
minutos depois do estouro da barragem de
fundão o major pousou o helicóptero e
cortou o motor de seu todo mundo pra
conseguir fazer com que a população
acreditar se que estava vendo um rio de
lama e que ia levar tudo que estava
passando por cima em frente e corresse
pra cima do do cemitério
eles conseguiram colocar 250 pessoas no
cemitério de paracatu e conseguiram
salvar essas 250 almas da corrente de
lama que estava descendo o fará conta
esse episódio na primeira edição no
primeiro episódio da memória de mariana
o olho dele fica marejado de lembrar
isso ele fala uma coisa muito bonita
fala cara você não acredita o que quer
lidar com a dor das pessoas
a partir desse momento eu nunca mais
joguei a dor de alguém dor não tem
religião dono tem cor do orador o
segundo personagem dessa história é o
seu antônio
se o antônio estava tomando uma
cervejinha no bar do jairo e quando foi
5 e 30 as desculpas do sul às 18 30 na
tarde que ele viu o helicóptero pousar
ele foi um dos moradores de paracatu foi
lá perguntar o que estava acontecendo na
hora da evacuação da população o fará
virou profissão antônio palocci antônio
você precisa de ajuda ele falou não meu
filho eu consigo chegar lá em cima
sozinho você tem que ajudar quem
realmente precisa
no terceiro episódio do documentário
memórias de mariana a gente foi até para
cá tu para entrevistar o san antonio san
antonio nos convidou a entrar na casa
dele ea gente ficou com ele cerca de
meia hora
ele passou um cafezinho em quando' e
começará a contar a história da vida
dele ele não abre mão de sair para cá
mtur
ele não quer sair de lá seu antônio
virou uma resistência ele é um símbolo
de resistência
ele é um símbolo que faz com que todo
mundo perceba que a história precisa ser
contada e lembrada para curar uma
epidemia
o seu antônio como se fosse uma lenda da
região se o antônio seria facilmente uma
canção do bernardo san antonio é um cara
que você senta para conversar e ele vai
contar detalhes da vida dele assim como
detalhes desse crime e ele fala sempre
com uma voz muito tranquila com o olho
claro um semblante cansado porém muito
firme do que ele fala de que ele só está
ali para dizer que a história persiste
se ele sai dali isso acaba nosso
terceiro personagem é um alemão
a gente tava quem mariana rodando o
quinto episódio da série e na tomada que
a gente fez um minuto de silêncio
tinha uma pessoa observando a gente de
longe ele teve coragem de se aproximar
da gente e perguntou o que a gente
estava fazendo eu falei com ele olha a
gente não é jornalista a gente não é
fotógrafo gente é um grupo de pessoas
que sentiu que precisava pra cá fazer
alguma coisa ea gente está retratando e
contando para manter a vigilância aqui
na região e não deixar que isso aqui
vire história que não foi resolvido a
história que manteve uma população no
estado de tristeza muito tempo
ele falou olha posso te contar uma
história foi claro não delegam ter ganho
ter jenson fique dois dias depois do dia
5 de novembro
ele estava na alemanha assistir o
noticiário do dia 7
e aí passou
o noticiário sobre o que aconteceu
especificamente em mariana
no brasil ele começou a chorar na
alemanha e na nossa frente pegou o
telefone na hora ligou para os filhos
incluindo o brasil
os filhos não entender o porquê pai
porque a barragem que eu ajudei a
construir estourou quando ele falou isso
pra gente o olho no olho dele não é que
tava marejado eu nunca vi o alemão
chorar
eu tenho alguns amigos alemães ele ele
estava com uma emoção brasileira de
mineiro genuína
você sabe o que está falando falou eu me
sentindo dvd vim aqui tudo bem que foi
há 20 anos atrás que estive aqui há 25
anos atrás mas eu tive que vinha que eu
tive que fazer alguma coisa
hogan ter ensinou pra gente que a
hipótese é ruim
em determinados momentos de epidemia de
tristeza não têm hipótese não tem
interesse em ter vírgula
tem que ter ação um alemão pega um avião
três dias depois de um acontecimento que
de certa forma ele se sentiu parte
responsável e veio aqui tomar
providências espalhar a cura e controlar
a epidemia de tristeza
o nosso quarto personagem é um rapaz que
hoje tem 13 anos de idade mas que no dia
5 tinha só 11 anos de idade e 10 para 11
estava aqui no economia acampando com a
escola dele nome dele mateus e ele é
nosso filho e à escola preocupada com o
que estava acontecendo
tirou os meninos do itacolomi eo matheus
foi impactado por esse resgate entre
aspas e depois pelo envolvimento da
família no memória de mariana a parte
minha mulher veio para mariano comigo
várias vezes os amigos as pessoas que
trabalhavam comigo ele foi impactado com
isso
um belo dia ele chegou em casa falou
'pai você não acredita no meu próximo
trabalho
a escola é sobre o desastre de mariana
falei com ele matheus pega sua mochila
chama mãe
a gente está indo pra mariana agora a
gente veio a mariana
ficamos hospedados no hotel providência
o mateus entrevistou a rose filha do seu
antônio que até outro dia era
recepcionista do hotel entrevistou um
monte de gente envolvida no crime
ambiental e voltou para belo horizonte
para fazer o trabalho dele e fez o
trabalho apresentou um belo dia a gente
está em casa ele chega com o caderno e
um recado da tutora dele dizendo o
seguinte paz
parabéns vocês fizeram com que seu filho
fosse convidado pelos professores para
dar essa aula junto com eles ea gente
escreveu um recado de volta os
professores professores parabéns por
entender que no mundo que a gente vive
nem sempre a gente que sabe de tudo e
por saber que uma criança de 11 anos
pode também ser professor e pode também
para um processo de cura importante
o matheus conseguiu no olhar dele
provocar na escola uma catarse para
fazer com que essa epidemia de tristeza
também fosse contida e o trabalho teve
de tudo ele inclusive falou da relação
da família com a região
essas quatro pessoas me ensinaram muito
durante o projeto ensina até hoje e eles
ensinam muitas coisas interessantes
sobre controle de epidemia
a primeira delas é a seguinte o ativismo
não é uma palavra ruim não é uma palavra
pejorativa
esses quatro personagens de mundos
distintos de idades distintas são
ativistas ativistas da felicidade
ativistas da cura ativismo não tem
ideologia ativismo não tem senão tem
vírgula tem fazer a segunda coisa é que
pra gente tratar 3
beleza é só um exemplo não tem outra não
tem outra como que a gente vai fazer
isso a gente mudar exemplo a gente não
falar abertamente a gente não assumir
responsabilidade todos eles assumiram
responsabilidade dentro do seu contorno
do seu universo do seu ecossistema
a responsabilidade de um aluno fazer um
trabalho de um alemão havia o brasil de
um tenente do corpo de bombeiro ou de um
morador de paracatu todos eles bateram
no peito falar tá no meu cpf
o que me cabe fazer e por último é que
não existe um super herói superman não
apareceu lá o batman também não
o que existe é um ser humano comum
pessoas comuns
se a gente for olhar profundamente o que
move empresas desastres controle de
epidemia cura são pessoas não existe a
entidade empresa a entidade existe um
grupo de pessoas que acreditou que fazer
algo possível
aqui a gente tem quatro grupos quatro
pessoas de um grupo nessa região aqui
tem milhares
eu conheço histórias inacreditáveis
histórias de pessoas comuns que fazem
coisas extraordinárias a gente controlar
a epidemia de tristeza
a gente precisa conta a história de
pessoas comuns que fazem coisas
extraordinárias
obrigado pessoal
[Aplausos]